[Music]
hi good afternoon welcome to digital
defense our weekly cybersecurity show
broadcasting from Bloomberg News
Washington DC bureau i'm jordan
robertson cybersecurity reporter for
bloomberg this is an interactive show we
cover a lot of topics and feet please
feel free wherever you're watching this
to write in with questions as we will we
will do our best to answer as many of
them as we can so we have an interesting
topic today there was a pretty crazy
arrest that was leaked in the Russian
press yesterday that has a lot of
implications potentially for what
happened in the u.s. in terms of
election hacking I'm going to scroll to
a new story here we'll just jump right
in this is what happened yesterday you
know a lead researcher for kaspersky lab
which is one of the biggest cyber
security companies was arrested in
Moscow as was a top official with with
the the Russian FSB which is the the you
know the the agency that followed along
after the KGB it's you know the main
intelligence agency within Russia and
the official who was arrested along with
this because persky lab researcher you
know was in charge of the you know
division of the FSB that American
officials believe was responsible for
the election hacking leading up to the
US presidential election this is
interesting for a lot of reasons we
don't know a lot about the charges and
we don't know a lot about the specifics
the investigation but we do actually
know a fair bit about this guy the
kaspersky guy because we at Bloomberg
had done a story back in 2015 you know
I'm kaspersky which kaspersky actually
didn't like very much but it was a good
story it was it was a good story about
you know the Russian military's
connections to kaspersky again kaspersky
is a is a Russian company and they do
business in Russia they're headquartered
in Russia and as any company that does
business in their home country knows you
develop ties to the government if you're
big enough so that's the that's the case
with Casper
ski so let me just walk this back a
little bit here I mean so what happened
was there's this guy named Ruslan
stoyanov that's the kaspersky lab
analyst he's in charge of a a division
within Kaspersky that handles me to
hacking related investigations it's kind
of a nebulous title kind of a vague job
description but nevertheless he's an
important individual within the company
works in their legal department you know
but has a kind of very specialized role
in terms of you know a liaison serving
as liaison to the Russian government yes
particularly the FSB and this arrest
kind of comes as a bolt out of blue
because cyber security researchers don't
really get arrested for much of anything
you know I mean a lot of the work that
these folks do is they analyze malware
you know their software is on client
networks and when those client networks
are attacked they'll analyze the malware
they'll generate signatures to block you
know future attacks things like that
it's an interesting business but it's
also a pretty kind of routine business
so for somebody to be involved with a
senior intelligence official who was
arrested and who's also believed to
potentially have been involved you know
with us election hacking you know raises
a lot of interesting questions so the
reason I wanted to discuss this guy on
our show today is again we don't know a
lot about the charges but we do know a
lot about this guy and that stems from
our earlier story so this guy Ruslan is
a former you know Russian law
enforcement official he was a cyber
crimes investigator and then he started
a security company before he worked for
before he worked for kaspersky he
started a denial of service protection
technology company he ran that for a
number of years and then that company
was absorbed into Kaspersky and i think
twenty twelve or twenty thirteen the
interesting part about that is this guy
again is not just some researcher in the
company who you know is alleged to have
gotten involved in some you know
potentially criminal behavior his
technology forms the basis for kaspersky
lab's denial of service protection which
you know many companies use many
companies in the US use but most
importantly you know the reason you know
many of you may be familiar with
Kaspersky is their biggest
business is consumer antivirus software
especially sold through deals like the
company has with best buy if you go in
the best buy and buy a computer you know
chances are kaspersky lab software will
either be pre-installed on your machine
or they'll try to sell it to you as you
check out so the company has a really
large presence in the US and again their
main product is kind of traditional
standard antivirus software however this
guy doesn't do that within the company
again he created a denial of service
protection technology but his actual
role within the company is again a
little vague he does hacking related
investigations which you can imagine you
know brings him and the company in
closer contact with the intelligence
services in Russia and law enforcement
and again he's you know former law
enforcement and as I said to top the
show we want to welcome questions here
and we've got one of them coming in
right now so I'll get back to this in a
second yeah the question that's come in
here is do you think Wall Street is safe
from hacking you know that mean the
answer is the answers nobody's safe from
hacking you know i mean the banks and
trading firms are a huge target you know
for hacking attempts because of you know
because of the ability to move money I
mean any money moving system as we've
heard it described to us by security
experts is going to be a big target for
attacks but it's also going to be you
know a large focus for defense as well
so you know the question is kind of
broad I mean do we think Wall Street
assay from hacking the answers they're
going to be no but there is a caveat
there I mean every bank every major
financial institution in the world now
that moves any amount of significant
amount of money knows that what is being
targeted on their networks primarily is
you know customer data is interesting
but it's not going to UM it you know
it's not going to crash the economy
money moving systems will so you know
everybody that we've talked to inside
stock exchanges and inside major banks
say that it's not a secret that the
hackers are targeting the systems and
and those tend to be very well protected
doesn't mean they can't be penetrated
doesn't mean they can't be compromised
but there is a lot of attention paid to
them next question here is has Putin
spoken publicly about the hacking what
does he say it's an interesting question
because Putin
before the election gave an interview to
bloomberg news television where he said
that the you know he was kind of coy
about the whole topic he was kind of
smirking of election hacky topic of
election hacking and he said that of
course we don't you know we in Russia
don't do hacking that's not it's not
something that we as a country do
however the leak of documents about the
Democratic Party was a public service
because it showed how party officials
were you know in league together against
the Bernie Sanders campaign so he called
it a public service that this hacked
information was leaked and he did it
with kind of a wry smile you know and
subsequent to that you know as the US
has released a lot of data you know
about why we believe the Russian
government you know was behind those
attacks you know Putin has kind of
reiterated earlier reiterated earlier
statements he'll never come right out
and say yeah we did the hacks and this
was this was a great thing but he has
stated repeatedly that this was that
served a public good next question here
is with potential border taxes and a
border wall should travelers be worried
about their security our travelers more
at risk of being hacked actually yes
depends what kind of depends what kind
of job you have frankly you know as
reporters or as diplomats or as business
people are often advised any time you
pass through a border crossing you know
you're passing from you know the the
oversight of one government to another
and those are actually really good
opportunities for you know malware to be
inserted on your computers now again if
you're kind of an ordinary you know
citizen and you're traveling for leisure
and you don't work in what might be
considered a sensitive job if you're not
intelligence analyst if you're not a
politician you know you probably don't
have a ton to worry about because the
you know the border agents you know are
not going to be interested in planning
now we're on your computer if however
you do occupy one of those sensitive
positions you know we in the media and
again you know folks in business and
government you know are often advised to
take a special care when that happens
because again once you cross over that
border into a foreign country you know
those border agents are employees of
that government and if that
government is interested in what's on
your computer what's on your phone you
know they can detain you at the airport
search through your stuff your stuff
disappears out of the room for 10
minutes and it comes back with stuff on
it that you don't want that's that's a
real concern that's a realistic concern
and that's why if you're doing any you
know extensive international travel and
you have reason to believe that you know
you may be in a position to be targeted
by a foreign government you know for
hacking that you bring along kind of you
leave your regular computer your regular
phone at home and you bring along kind
of burner devices so you know clean
devices have never been used before and
that don't have any sensitive data on
them and then when you get back you know
you wipe the operating system and you
start over so I hope that helps next
question here is is the u.s. retaliating
against Russia I would actually invert
this question by way of answering it so
this arrest some people are seeing this
arrest as a form of retaliation by
Russia against the US for the data that
we revealed so against the theory at
this point it's not proven but there is
a theory going around that because you
know the Russian intelligence official
who was arrested you know basically ran
the unit that US officials believe was
responsible for part of the selection
hacking you know and that this kaspersky
lab analyst was arrested at the same
time you know that perhaps they passed
you know intelligence to us officials
perhaps they were working you know on
the payroll for the CIA again
speculation but the timing the you know
the position of the Russian intelligence
official the fact that Kaspersky Labs
this individual you know has close ties
to the government by the nature of his
job so I would say there are some folks
here in Washington and in the security
community you know who believe that this
these arrests of this kaspersky
individual and the FSB individual you
know may well be retaliation by Russia
for leaked information out of that
country inn in regards the question is
the u.s. retaliating against Russia you
know they've the US has imposed
sanctions on a number of individuals
notably not including the one who was
arrested
and leaked yesterday but his agency is
kind of well known you know we've heard
you know president Trump talk about how
sanctions are not effective you know
lots and lots of folks believe that they
are because what that does is they know
the sanctions limit the the ability to
travel for a lot of these individuals
the ability to get access to any funds
stored you know across border so you
know every data point we have you know
shows that sanctions do have an effect
and that's the primary we're primarily
way the u.s. is retaliating against
Russia you know at present for the
election hacking but an interesting side
note would be you know if these arrests
are related to the election hacking and
if these arrests are related to any
information that the u.s. disclosed
prior to the election of president Trump
you know one important historical note
here to remember is the reason the US
released so much data you know about the
election hacking wasn't necessarily
because the Obama administration felt
that it was a grave danger to democracy
he may have believed that but that
wasn't the stated reason the reason that
much information was released may have
been in part that but it was also
largely because you know now president
Trump you know was so so adamant that it
didn't occur so there was a big push
within the intelligence community to
release as much data as possible about
those election hacks so that would be in
the public domain Congress could
investigate at the FBI could investigate
it and there would be some public
discussion about that and what folks in
the intelligence community are talking
about right now is you know if any
sensitive data you know appeared in
those reports that you know Moscow was
able to trace back to leaks out of their
country and if those leaks had anything
to do with this this guy Ruslan and the
the intelligence official in Moscow you
know that's potentially really damaging
to our ability to collect intelligence
if indeed and again unproven and this is
speculation if indeed these guys were
actual intelligence assets whether
witting or unwitting intelligence assets
for the US the next question come in
here is you know how unusual is it for a
high-level executive like rustling to be
charged with treason does it happen in
the US as well it's a good
question I forgot to mention this the
charge that these guys are being
arrested under is treason now that
doesn't necessarily mean the same in
Russia as it does here it can but it
also encompasses you know a lot of other
things as per the statute in in Russia
you know basically anything that could
be seen as harming the state's interest
you know that could be you know all the
way from you know sharing national
security secrets with the US government
you know down to sharing information
that may have made its way to the US
that you know Russia sees as damaging to
its interest but yes these these
individuals are being charged and
arrested under you know at recent
statute it's very rare I mean we've had
you know instances in the US where
individuals have been arrested from the
intelligence community and charged and
convicted of treason but you know those
have typically been the kind of classic
espionage model where they you know
these are us individuals who become
assets of a foreign government and
they're usually accepting payment and
that's typically the way this stuff
works you know we don't know the nature
of the alleged offenses here against
these folks you know but if it involved
and again we're speculating here but if
it involved you know the senior Russian
official passing information to a
private sector individual like rustling
you know and that information somehow
making it to the US or you know some
other foreign government you know that's
a pretty interesting chain of custody
when it comes to you know really
sensitive national security information
so it's it's not unprecedented that we
would see an arrest like this however
considering the circumstances and if
there is a connection to our election
hacking here in the US the chain of
custody is actually what's interesting
here because this isn't some soul
intelligence officials been corrupted by
payments from the CIA you know this
would involve a number of people in the
private sector as well you know next
question here is what kind of
legislation does that you have us have
in regards to cyber activity in cyber
attacks well this question touches on an
issue that it really has been a swamp
here in in Washington I mean you know
there have been folks for pushing for
years to pass through cybersecurity
legislation and despite the kind of
generic sounding title you know really
what that legislation has been trying to
do is give companies
legal immunity to share attack and other
data with the US government and there
are a lot of legitimate reasons to
oppose this legislation which the
government says look we know it's
happening our government networks we
know it's happening at the network level
because the NSA and other agencies have
very good visibility at the ISP level at
the telco level that's historically what
they've done they don't have great
visibility into what's happening inside
companies they can see what goes into
companies what comes out of companies
but inside those networks they they
really don't have great visibility
unless the company has previously let
them in so what a lot of folks here in
Washington been trying to do for a long
time is to say we're going to give those
companies legal immunity for sharing
data you know that may be in violation
of state privacy laws like if a bank
like JP Morgan says okay FBI we're going
to share all the attack data we have
with you you know but we need protection
that if we release customer data the two
things won't happen one that we won't be
sued successfully because we did that
and to that our competitors won't get it
that it won't leak or won't be hacked
you know by the Chinese of the Russian
so that's why that legislation has
really stalled out you know there isn't
meaningful sharing of that sort right
now and it's kind of unlikely that we're
going to see any meaningful change in
that because of those those legal issues
that that involves next question here is
you know could private companies or
organizations retaliate against Russia
independently you know this is another
issue that we've we've studied quite a
bit in you know in cyber security
because if you're a company let's take
the dnc for example if you're an
organization a political organization or
company you've been hacked by Russia you
have a pretty good idea through your own
network telemetry and security software
of where that data went let's say let's
say you're able to identify the server
in Brazil where as was the case with JP
Morgan when it got hacked it's hack data
went to a server in Brazil the bank knew
where that data was but by law the bank
is prohibited from taking any action to
go get that data back from that server
because that would be hacking as well
it's also prohibited by law from hacking
back and taking out the server's of
whoever it believed you know did those
attacks the reason that's illegal
I mean it's emotionally satisfying to be
able to say you hacked me I know who you
are through various mechanisms cyber
security software is very good these
days I'm going to hit you back the
reason that's illegal is is a pretty
straightforward one you know many many
hack hacks computers or computers that
hackers use to hack other people you
know are hack themselves so it's my
computer or your computer your home
computer your server or whatever and you
know hackers piggyback on those machines
to hack other people so JP Morgan or the
DNC gets upset about their hacking
attack you know and they hit back the
chances that they're hitting back at a
peaceful person's computer or a you know
just a kind of an innocent victims
computer is pretty high so there are
lots of folks within the business world
and the political world who say this
should be a lot easier to do but the
concept that comes up especially in the
government realm where the government
can you know hit back at whomever it
chooses is this idea of cyber escalation
it's a you know it's a lot harder to
stop you know a tit for tat battle in
cyberspace then actually it is on the
battlefield because it's so much easier
to launch a cyber attack it's so much
easier to disguise the nature and the
origin of those attacks so the you know
the potential for escalation and pretty
dramatic escalation is something that
military and intelligence officials
think about you know a lot so you know
so with that we're going to be wrapping
up here and i do want to let you know
we're going to be following the story
closely you know this there may even be
more arrests that you know and if there
are we will certainly report on them
here you known as their further
development so you know bring it to to
y'all next week and as always if you
want to write me some questions offline
my twitter handle is at jordan are 1000
thanks for everybody for for watching
and we'll see you again next week
[Music]